- Feedback processes, evaluation cycles up
or out principal working
in consulting can be tough.
It can be a challenge.
And there is for sure, lots
of pressures attached to it.
And a big part of that are
the constant evaluation processes.
Every half a year,
sometimes even every quarter,
you will get a formal evaluation where
your performance is being
assessed, where you will be looked
at and people will ask themselves where
this consultant Heinrich
or whatever your name is.
How did this person perform?
Welcome to another coffee
break here on my channel
Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich and
on Firm learning and
I want to help you to become
successful in the first years
of your career.
In today, we're going to talk
about the evaluation
processes for consultants.
And specifically, I will share
with you how consultants are evaluated.
What are the criteria that
are being applied for your
performance as a consultant assistant.
And of course it's important to understand
that these processes always
differ slightly firm, by firm.
But in my experience, also
in talking to other friends
working in other firms, I
just know that it really comes
down to three key criteria
pretty much all firms are using.
So in today's video, I
will explain to you what
these three criteria are,
what you can do to be rated
well, to be assessed
well in these criteria
and also to talk about how the performance
of a good consultant
differs from the performance
of a great consultant.
So what you can do to
go from good to great.
Let's start by talking about the first
of three key dimensions that are used
by most firms to evaluate your
performance as a consultant.
And these are your analytical abilities.
What does this exactly mean?
What is measured here?
This means how good you are
at structuring problems,
at solving problems
and working with data,
getting insights from data.
This is all what's in here.
And especially for junior consultants,
this often means working in Excel, right?
So crunching numbers in Excel,
working with spreadsheets
getting insights out
of data, but then also
your contribution and team
problem solving sessions.
So if you are sitting
together with your team
maybe your partners flying in
with your project lead
with other team colleagues
you're debating a problem from
your work from the project.
How well are you to contribute to that?
How much of a value add are
you to solve the problems
at hand that the team is facing?
All of this is part of
your analytical abilities
and all of this would be
measured in this regard.
So let's all talk about
how a good consultant
distinguishes him or herself
from a great consultant
in regards to these analytical abilities.
So a good consultant is doing well
what he or she is being told.
So you might sit together
with a project lead,
The project lead provides you a data set
and the project lead asks you
to conduct an analysis based
on this data set.
So good consultant would do exactly
that would prepare a clean
nice analysis would crunch
the numbers, get to a result.
But the great consultant
would go one step further.
The great consultant in the middle
of the analysis might realize
that the actual question
at hand, cannot really be
answered by these numbers
that are included in the
dataset, this great consultant
and would realize that
probably he or she would need
some other data inputs to really
get to a great conclusion.
So instead of now just doing,
just completing this analysis
because this is what the project
lead taught him or herself
the great consultant would go out,
potentially talk to another client,
get this data that would actually
be needed, then integrated
in the analysis and then just
prepare the good final result.
Then really also answers
the question at hand.
The second evaluation
criteria I want to talk
about are your team abilities.
So what exactly does this
mean, team abilities?
This is how well you
contribute to the overall
success of a team.
Are you just the lonely wolf,
just working for yourself
or are you actually a team player,
also supporting other people,
supporting the team.
One question always is
to what extent you really
contribute to a positive
and inclusive atmosphere in the team room.
Sometimes things can be tough.
Your team might struggle
with a difficult client.
Maybe you need to work late
for several days in a row.
And all of these things can really take
a toll on team morale.
Are you then the person
who always complaints?
adds to all this negativity,
draws everybody down
or are you the person who
despite difficult circumstances
is able to increase
the team morale, to contribute to create
an edge to a overall positive atmosphere.
This is always a key
question that also I like to
use when evaluating
teammates on this criteria.
But then it's also about other
things, how you communicate
how you work together with your teammates.
So if you get some tasks
from your project lead, are you reliable?
Can you be trusted that you get the done
that you really would be a very
very best to complete the
task as you've been asked
or maybe you see your teammates
struggling with something?
Are you taking the time to
sit together with a teammate?
Maybe it's a teammate, which
is a bit more junior than you.
Maybe it's an intern.
Are you taking the time
to help that intern to
develop that intern?
All of these are qualities
which are looked at
which are considered when
making this decision.
So again, let's talk
about what distinguishes a good consultant
from a great consultant.
When we talk about these team abilities.
A good concise in this regard is reliable.
He or she would get all the things done.
And then the project lead asked
that consultant to do and the project
lead would ask the consultant
to potentially also pick
up some tasks from another colleague
even though these tasks
are not necessarily part
of your work you're responsible for,
then you would happily do
that as a good consultant.
The great consultant
would go one step further.
So let's think back
about the situation where
maybe things are a bit tough,
Team morale is down,
Things are a bit difficult at the moment,
The great consultant would
take initiative would ask him
or herself, what can
I really do personally
to contribute to that?
And you, one of the things
that this great consultant
and then could do is
suggest to do a team event.
And this is a great,
concise, and could then
even research potential things
that could be done close
to the office location,
could organize it all
book it into the calendars
and make sure that everybody
is having a good time.
These things are always
great because of course
it's difficult to do this on
top of all your other duties
also for the project lead,
doing things like that
organizing things like that on top
of everything else can be quite a burden.
So everybody will be super happy
if you're taking care of this.
And of course, if you
do this proactively just
taking the initiative, organizing this
this will always be considered
to be a great team player
great contributing to the
overall team atmosphere.
The third evaluation criteria
on are your client abilities.
So how well are you to work
with and interact with your clients.
This can take all kinds of forms.
For sure, your ability
to lead client meetings
to need interviews with clients
to communicate things away
to clients will play a role.
Your also often new abilities to
create written documents
that are then presented
in front of clients that are
shown in front of clients
goes into that as well.
But also your overall ability to
build a trust-based relationship
to the extent to which the
client really wants to work
with you because the client sees you
as a trusted advisor with whom he
or she would love to talk to
use you as a sparring partner
get some feedback from
you on ideas, on all kinds
of topics that the client
is currently working on.
And trust me as a project
lead, you notice that,
you notice if a client just randomly walks
into your team room and
wants to talk to some
of your consultants because the
client really enjoys talking
to the person just would
love to get an opinion
on that person.
And here for sure a good junior
consultant would be able to
build a great working relationship
with the consultant where
you can in an effective way
work together, exchange
some ideas, iterate
on some documents, really work
on an end product together
but the great consultant button
would go one step further.
So not only is this
consultant using the client to
get some information, to get some data
but the consultant would really
want to build a relationship
with the client
the relationship where
both parties benefit,
relationship where potentially even after
the end of the project, both
of you would stay in touch
because especially when you
then get more and more senior
these relationships are for
sure and insanely the important
because these relationships
are the starting position
of new projects of new client discussions
with them potentially follow-on-projects
might evolve on in the future.
Here's one tip
I got from a project
lead, I worked with one
of my first projects, was
that on every single project
you should try to pick
at least one person, at
least one client with whom
you really enjoy working
and then try to build a
friendship with this client
try to stay in contact right
to this client every six months
or so.
Stay in contact with this
person, just to build also
your professional network,
because maybe this client
at the time when you work
with this person, isn't even
that senior, isn't even that important
in the client organization,
but in the same way
that you progress throughout
your career, the same way often
then clients are progressing
through their careers as well.
So junior client who's junior today, maybe
in 3, 4, 5, 6, 7 years,
once you are a partner is
pretty important pretty
senior client indeed.
And if you start dealing
your professional network
like this early on,
chances are pretty high
that besides all the other
benefits that you've caused also
have by gaining your valuable contact
by expanding your network,
chances are high, that then
this would really benefit you
also in the long-term goal
of potentially acquiring
new projects for your firm.
I love to hear from you now
what is your experience
with evaluation processes?
So if, if any tips you'd like to share
just write a comment below
in the comment section.
And as you know, I do my very best to
answer every single
comment that you write.
If you took any value
out of this video at all
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to
this channel to stay up
to date on all my content also
started to become more active
on both Twitch and Tik TOK.
So check that out as well.
There's a link to that
in the video description
I'd also like to give a shout
out to all the members of, Firm Learning.
Thanks so much for your support.
And if you want to continue
your learning journey,
I suggest you check out the video
on the up or out principle,
which is very closely related
to everything we just discussed today.
So links, some are above here.
Check it out to learn more about this.
My name is Heinrich.
I'm the creator of Firm Learning.
I release new videos every
single week here on my channel.
So see you again next Saturday.
Good weekend to all of you.
And bye-bye.